ils sont là ils sont prêts alec
castonguay montréal emmanuelle
latraverse à toronto michel s'est logé à
montréal bonjour messieurs dames bonjour
jours emmanuel je commence par vous êtes
à toronto où vous êtes allez vous
promener jade de vous entendre cette
bataille qui sera rangée entre dans
certaines circonscriptions les néo
démocrates et les libéraux
oui ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'on
sent que le discours commence à changer
sur le terrain tant du côté des libéraux
que du côté du npd on me dit écoute et
c'est une chose pendant le début de la
campagne de marteler le besoin du
changement le besoin de change pour le
besoin de changement mais un moment
donné il faut aller au delà de ça et le
plus on voit les chiffres et les appuis
du parti conservateur baissé en ontario
plus de part et d'autre un [ __ ] que du
côté du parti libéral on tente de dire
aux électeurs le maintenant c'est le
temps de clarifier c'est pour vous de
choisir pour lequel vous allez voter
ce qui est intéressant c'est que du côté
du npd
on le voit les pancartes sont assez peu
subtile s'est défait harper le npd se
présente et si vraiment comme le parti
capable de gagner
alors que du côté du parti libéral on en
voit vraiment le message aux électeurs
écoutez vous l'avez le choix vous avez
le temps pensez-y
mais sur les bureaux qui ont misé sur
leurs plans l'infrastructure jeu fait
vous laisse écouter monsieur mulcair et
monsieur trudeau
car pour vraiment apporter du changement
il faut vraiment avoir le courage de ses
convictions
il faut avoir des objectifs clairs pour
le canada et un plan pour les autres
c'est ça le changement que je veux
apporter à toi j'ai bâti mon plan en
fonction de mon expérience et de mes
valeurs et nous on a l'équipe pour
réussir nous avons un plan clair en
trois points
investir dans nos infrastructures pour
créer des emplois et demeurer
compétitifs faire croître la classe
moyenne en lui accordant des baisses
d'impôts et aider ceux qui travaillent
fort pour joindre la classe moyenne
le plan en trois points patrice
attendez-vous à l'entendre de nouveau
c'est un peu la nouvelle ligne pour
donner une cohérence aux messages des
libéraux les candidats sur le terrain
nous disent ici que c'est plus facile
avec c'est d'aller voir les jambes d'un
côté nous on est élu on veut investir
dans les infrastructures de transport en
commun on voit résoudre rapidement vos
problèmes sur le terrain surtout dans
les batailles de toronto pour le vote
progressiste
le npd par ailleurs une âme remettre sur
le nez de justin trudeau son appui à la
loi contre le terrorisme
elle suit je vous laisse écouter au
leader numéro
soyons et eros aux messieurs ça sera pas
l'ange de la parole mais je sais manuel
une seconde vous avez parlé à des gens
en compte et housses prise en charge par
exemple et puis comment ils voient cette
campagne ils sont déchirés entre quoi il
ya beaucoup beaucoup d'aidé si sur le
terrain des indécis qui veulent défaire
les conservateurs et qui veulent voter
au bon endroit il ya toute une logique
de vote stratégique qui est en train de
s'installer en tant qu'homme la campagne
est longue les gens sur le terrain
indique t on eu le temps de les écouter
de se faire une tête elles ne se sentent
pas pressé je vous dirais de se brancher
c'est bien aussi rapidement que ça se
dire que c'est un compte et qui est
intéressant parce qu'il a été changée et
donc que vraiment des poches de vote
différente des votes de famille un vote
très urbain dans des comptes et dans des
conditions de jeu donc on va surveiller
seul à 19 au soir
michel c et alex t'amusant parce que
j'étais aujourd'hui sur la rue
sainte-catherine je faisais des appels
un vox pop donc j'ai parlé à beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de monde et je pense
que c'est la phrase qui est revenu le
plus souvent on a encore le cas de
réfléchir on sait pas trop que ça allait
dans toutes les directions
ici à montréal mais revenons à la
bataille de toronto donc c'est loin et
on le disait hier là c'est très loin
d'être figée et donc le résultat est
totalement incertaine celle c'est oui
d'abord on est à la mi campagne
aujourd'hui là et même à la mi-campagne
il ya encore plus
il reste plus de tanks une élection
normale alors on a le temps oui on l'olt
et il faudra voir quelle allure cette
élection l'emprunt au cours des deux
prochaines semaines par exemple si
je prends très emprunté de france sacrée
si la tendance se maintient et que
monsieur un peu continue de perdre des
appuis il se pourrait bien que la
question qui se pose à ce moment là
c'est parti on ne remplace que là est la
question des isoloirs ce soit ça ça soit
pas qu'il vaut mieux battre afin qu'un
peu choix plus dans le soit plus dans le
décor à ce moment à leurs boules du
doubs les programmes qu'ils prennent
leur à tous les programmes qui prennent
leur importance d'où la personnalité
aussi des déjà les principes qu'ils
prennent qui prennent de l'importance
alors on n'est pas rendu là on n'est pas
rendus à la question de l'isoloir et il
faudra voir si si douce il est aussi
possible que les conservateurs reprenne
du poil de la bête aussi c'est pas
l'exclure alec est ce que monsieur
trudeau sa position de dire maintenant
dix jours de dire moi je vais faire des
difficiles pendant au moins 3 ans pour
réinvestir dans les infrastructures etc
est-ce que ça notariaux c'est pas ça
leur rappelle pas un gouvernement
néo-démocrate justement avec c'est un
peu complexe l'ontario a nié plusieurs
ontario il ya la grande région de
toronto le 9 05 les banlieues sud de
l'ontario plus industriels
manufacturiers 1h l'ontario me faudra
voir avec qui cette promesse leur
raisonne en particulier moi je vois avec
une explication peut-être plus terre à
terre
est ce que c'est une politique complexe
dévoilée par justin trudeau qui est la
remontée des libéraux le simple fait que
pris une position claire et nette ce
qu'il n'avait pas fait depuis des mois
justin trudeau quoi fait depuis la
légalisation de la marijuana là il a
tergiversé fait des guerres pas voulu
prendre des positions claires dans la
plupart des débats qui ont eu lieu à la
chambre des communes
il y avait beaucoup de libéraux parce
que la marque libérale est très forte en
ontario depuis que justin trudeau et là
il était promis à part dans les sept ou
huit derniers mois où les néo démocrates
avaient remonté mais beaucoup de
libéraux voulaient voter pour justin
trudeau avait l'impression que leur chef
était pas à la hauteur mais que la
marque l'esprit libéral devait avoir un
vote fort et là le fait que je t'ai
trouvé pris une position ce soit assumée
même c'est pas nécessairement une bonne
politique publique
aucun économiste qui dit que le canada
besoin d'un bassin de relance sur la
renégociation de prêt une position et je
pense que cela est très bien on va
regarder une seconde
petit extrait de publicité si vous le
voulez bien
vous avez compris l'essentiel donc il
attaque attaque le npd en disant c'est
pas le tas de faire des compressions et
cetera
je fais écouter l'autre on en parle
après ça c'est une publicité et
conservateurs qu'on écoute une partie
alors on le voit très bien c'est les
mots clés à emmanuel donc les
conservateurs qui disent les deux autres
partis vont vous enfoncer dans des
visites dans des déficits
nous on est capitaine prudent et alain
verte et libéraux qui disent on a besoin
de réinvestir en fait sur place je
voudrais qu est ce qui est intéressant
au delà de ce qui est dit dans la
crainte dans la publicité du parti
libéral c'est l'image on ne met pas
besoin de liquide de l'entendre pour
comprendre le message que vous fassiez
juste être dos est cet escalier qui
descend alors que l'ue essaie de
remonter
c'est là dessus que les libéraux ont
frappé pour ironiser pressé y est de
frapper les esprits si vous passez
l'expression ils verront croit avoir
trouvé dans une cohérence à l'ensemble
de leurs messages investir le contraste
avec les autres chefs
ecce terra ce qu'on voit chez les
conservateurs c'est c'est très classique
c'est très dans les dents dans les mines
dans le ton de ce qui dit généralement
que quelque chose là pour vraiment
inverser une tendance contre eux je le
sais pas et de remarquable dans cette
publicité là c'est la ligne la fin on
dit surtout mais ça peut y est pas
parfait mais au moins il est compétent
ce message est quand même pour leurs
armes en vue dans ce genre de film est
donc une humilité qu'on n'avait pas
beaucoup vu messieurs c'est tout le
temps qu'on a
emmanuel a été
en vedette parce que vous étiez à
toronto et on fera un changement fera
une table tournante
la prochaine fois langer je vais donner
plus de sens comme les partis politiques
finalement on compte les minutes
je n'aurai plus de vous messieurs merci
bonjour au brasero se voit demain salut